tf1 20 heures avec roger gicquel
détournement du dc-10 d'alitalia
les quatre terroristes kurdes libère 140
des 175 passagers sur l'aéroport de rome
monsieur guirec en france trois heures
de tête à tête avec le président valéry
giscard d'estaing à rambouillet pour des
relations franco polonaise privilégier
la fièvre de l'or des hausses en
dents-de-scie une spéculation dangereuse
des explications dal avait l'air un
portrait du pilote français automobiles
rené arnoux meilleur aux premiers essais
de monza
bonsoir un détournement d'avion à
occuper aujourd'hui l'avant scène de
l'actualité en plus direz vous oui mais
encore une fois les auteurs de ce
détournement d'un dc 8 de la compagnie
alitalia avec 175 passagers et 11
membres d'équipage qui assurait la
liaison téhéran rome via beyrouth
les auteurs de ce détournement voulait
sans doute exprimé les droits d'une
minorité opprimée
les quatre pirates de l'air sont des
kurdes oui ces kurdes si violemment
combattu tour à tour par l'irak et
l'iran est mise en déroute
au début de la semaine dans leurs places
fortes par les troupes de l'ayatollah
khomeini ces pirates kurdes se sont
emparés de l'avion après l'escale de
beyrouth avec l'intention de conduire à
la havane à cuba où se tient justement
le sommet des non alignés
mais il fallait faire le plein d'essence
alors le pilote a été obligé de faire le
cap sur nice mais les autorités
françaises fidèles à leur doctrine
d'ailleurs de nom accueille des pirates
de l'air ont interdit l'atterrissage en
mettant des camions en travers de la
piste et finalement c'est à rome que
l'avion s'est posé rome d'où nous parle
notre correspondant permanent claude
brovelli après la libération de 140 des
passagers sur 75
il ya un peu plus d'une heure plus de
brevets dit
une reporter vers cuba les prestations
engagé dès l'atterrissage de l'avion sur
l'aéroport de fiumicino
on était mené l'équipe i tambour battant
que moi dit en arabe voici en anglais
elles ont duré deux heures résultat
après un peu plus d'une heure et demie
140 des 175 passagers sont libérés par
citigroup
on peut voir de loin certains d'entre
eux courir aux hits envers les bobbies
autocar de la compagnie italienne contre
des otages libérés
les quatre clubs ont obtenu que les
citernes de l'avion fois rempli de 70
litres de kérosène devant leur permettre
d'aller à la havane sans escale aucun
des employés de l'aéroport l'a
d'ailleurs vous le conduire le camion
citerne à lannion et il semble que ce
soit un policier qui cette fois chargé
de l'opération
alors que le trafic sur l'aéroport roma
n'a pas été interrompue un dispositif de
sécurité adapté a été mis en place et
lannion est tenu en permanence dans la
mire des tireurs d'élite
une centaine de policiers appartenant à
un groupe d'intervention spéciales sont
également sur place
mais les 1/2 pas que les italiens est
envisagé nation de forces anti
terroristes
aux dernières nouvelles le commando
kurde aurait également réclamé la venue
d'un équipage nous ment pour effecter le
trajet les cas la ran les amantes ils
disent devant se présenter tout l'avion
complètement nue
selon les prévisions il devrait donc
laisser une trentaine de base un
événement à bord de l'avion qui
transportait départ essentiellement
désorientant parmi lesquels ils y
gagnent en a informé ni à ma
connaissance le problème kurde n'a pas
été évoquée au sommet des non alignés de
cuba le sommet des non alignés de la
havane était trop occupé avec les
problèmes du cambodge et l'egypte ce
sommet s'achève dans quelques heures
mais déjà raymond girard en tire un
premier bilan
le sixième sommet des pays non-alignés
réunis à la havane sous la houlette
fidel castro aura eu pour effet
principal d'accentuer de façon
dramatique le clivage entre les
partisans du non-alignement engagé à la
cubaine
c'est à dire dans le camp socialiste
et les modérés qui sous la conduite du
maréchal tito souhaite maintenir le
mouvement
or de l'allégeance à l'un des deux blocs
castro et ses amis vietnamiens éthiopien
malgache irakien et autres
obtiendront-ils une condamnation de
l'egypte voire une exclusion du
mouvement pour avoir signé une paix
séparée avec israël obtiendront-ils une
reconnaissance du régime de rentes
sarine imposé au cambodge par hanoï
ce qui forcerait les modérés à voter
pour la reconnaissance du détestable
régime de pol pot tu véritables
fossoyeurs de son peuple
jusqu'à ce matin les extrémistes avaient
le vent en poupe et semblait devoir
l'emporter sur ces deux points
essentiels mais une france yves deux
dernières heures des modérés est venue
tout remettre en question et c'est tard
dans la nuit que l'émotion finale seront
adoptées de ces décisions graves dépend
le sort du prochain sommet qui se
réunira en irak en septembre 1982 et
l'on peut déjà se demander combien des
95 pays réunis à laval se retrouveront à
bagdad
à propos de la présence de troupes
soviétiques de combat dans l'île de cuba
est bien jimmy carter doit faire dans un
moment d'un moment à l'autre
une déclaration officielle pour dire
comment ses troupes soviétiques ont été
repérés le 17 août dernier
c'est ce qu'il dit c'est ce que dit la
maison blanche et aussi pour dire les
conclusions qu'ils en tirent sur les
relations entre les états unis et
l'union soviétique
edward gierek le numéro un polonais est
l'hôte de la france depuis 12h30
aujourd'hui et jusqu'à demain soir
je devrais plutôt dire qu'il est l'hôte
de monsieur giscard d'estaing dans la
plus grande discrétion au château de
rambouillet
le premier secrétaire du parti ouvrier
unifié polonais a atterri sur la base
militaire d'evreux
ce qui passe ce qui n'est pas habituel
un certain nombre d'entretiens sont
prévues entre les deux chefs d'état mais
aucun ordre du jour n'a été fixée
on prévoit juste un petit communiqué
final demain soir en fait cette
rencontre de rambouillet n'est que la
suite d'un tête à tête quasi permanent
entre des plus hauts responsables de la
france et de la pologne
comme s'il y avait des liens tout à fait
privilégié entre les deux pays
l'un avec l'autre à l'ouest et entre les
deux hommes qui semble fort bien son
temps gérard saint paul valéry giscard
d'estaing edward gierek deux hommes deux
styles deux horizons politiques mais
aussi une rencontre qui est devenu une
habitude
entre les visites officielles au nombre
de deux et trois non officielle de
travail avec celle d'aujourd'hui
l'album de ce dialogue privilégié de
voyage en pologne 3 en france comporte
déjà de nombreuses pages mais elle ne
s'illustrent ces pages que des
rencontres d'état sur les autres privés
ou de travail silence caméra et
discrétion à l'écart des blocs le
président de la république et le premier
secrétaire du groupe du parti ouvrier
unifié polonais pratiquent un dialogue
original cet échange de vues n'a pas
d'équivalent en effet cela tient à une
volonté commune de développer des
relations qui souhaite exemplaire pour
les rapports est ouest c'est à dire à la
pointe de la détente mais aussi appuyé
entre la france et la pologne sur une
solide tradition historiques d'amitié
pour autant le chef de l'état et le
numéro un polonais n'en cultive pas des
sujets de conversation dégager du
présent et des soucis concrets qui sont
grands d'abord la pologne sur le plan
économique à des difficultés de
trésorerie énorme et un endettement
sérieux y compris vis-à-vis de la france
mais ce n'est pas une raison on dira
direct à valéry giscard d'estaing pour
nous laisser en cet état et pour ne pas
nous aider à industrialiser le pays en
participant au prochain plan quinquennal
c'est un pari sur l'avenir car
foncièrement la pologne a du répondant
mais il y à des enjeux politiques aussi
à ce dialogue
la détente et la sécurité pour préparer
la suite d'helsinki à madrid en 1980 et
au delà encore de cet aspect
diplomatique qui semble théorique mais
qui règle les rapports est ouest les
relations directes de la france et de la
pologne s'inscrivent dans tout un
ensemble ou l'ostpolitik allemande la
politique à l'est reste active la
coopération franco allemande ne se
dément pas mais elle n'exclut pas une
certaine compétition pacifique entre
paris et bonn sur les places d'europe
orientale
en ces temps de grands débats sur la
défense ou la pologne
encore traumatisé par les partages qu'il
a subi dans le passé a horreur du vide
et de la solitude
en dépit de son appartenance à un pacte
militaire auquel varsovie a donné son
nom
on pourrait penser qu'après les vacances
les hommes politiques sont tous bien en
forme pourtant je peux vous dire que ça
n'apparaît pas tout à fait dans les
sondages en tout cas pas dans celui du
figaro magazine qui paraît demain c'est
un sondage sofres publié sous le titre
la désaffection la désaffection étant le
contraire de l'affection et de la
popularité
c'est comme si on voulait nous faire
croire à travers ce sondage que les
personnalités politiques avaient perdu
en cette rentrée n'ont pas de leur
bronzage mais de leur crédibilité alors
à la tête de l'état on trouve en tout
cas une perte de confiance assez nette
pour monsieur giscard d'estaing 49% des
français lui font confiance contre 54 au
mois de juillet perte de confiance très
forte pour raymond barre 29 % seulement
des réponses de réponses favorables
contre 30
6 au mois de juillet mais pratiquement
toutes les personnalités politiques
perdent un ou deux points qu'elles
soient de la majorité ou de l'opposition
simone veil est celle qui perd le plus
six points seul jacques chirac et
jacques chaban-delmas refont un peu de
terrain dans la majorité ainsi que
pierre mauroy dans l'opposition toujours
dominé par la personnalité de michel
rocard assez loin devant françois
mitterrand
le premier ministre n'a pas été très
bien accueillis aujourd'hui à saint pol
de léon dans le finistère il a eu droit
à une manifestation de 3000 personnes
organisée par les syndicats les
organisations paysannes protestant
contre la politique économique du
gouvernement qui pour le plus grand
nombre atteint le seuil de
l'insupportable a dit l'un des porte
parole des salariés
le premier ministre venait participer à
l'université des jeunes giscardiens du
mouvement autrement notre envoyé spécial
patrice duhamel nous dit ce qu'a été
cette journée
raymond barre face au jeune et bien
raymond barre face aux jeunes a voulu
c'est clair poursuivre sa
contre-offensive dans la tourmente face
aux contestations vous venez différents
luz ou encore c'est un message de
confiance qu'il a voulu transmettre à
ces jeunes et à travers eux sans doute à
l'opinion publique toute entière il l'a
fait à partir d'un constat d'une réponse
globale aux critiques et de
l'affirmation d'un projet le constat
d'abord les changements dit raymond
barre s'accélère nous sommes à l'une des
phases de l'histoire où la sélection
entre les nations et impitoyable il faut
donc prendre un grand tournant pour cela
deuxième point il faut d'après le
premier ministre écarté les sursauts des
nostalgiques du passé abandonné les
pistes fausses comme la fuite en avant
où l'étatisme ne pas se laisser prendre
par le rêve ou par l'illusion traduction
confirmation pas de changement de cap
enfin à montbard développe son projet
pour une france dit-il indépendante et
moderne qui doit prendre conscience de
ses atouts le but construire une société
solidaire et quelques priorités comme
une économie compétitive une agriculture
dynamique ou encore une dépendance
énergétique réduite c'est donc à partir
de ce schéma que raymond barre qui a
notamment critiqué les professionnels de
la démoralisation que raymond barre a
donc construit son intervention pendant
deux heures devant ces jeunes
giscardiens du mouvement autrement c'est
clair le tout à l'heure le premier
ministre voulait apporter la preuve
qu'au delà de la gestion quotidienne des
affaires et bien le gouvernement pense
aussi à l'avenir au moyen terme je vous
propose maintenant de suivre vous allez
l'entendre
extrait de cette intervention du premier
ministre tout ceci nous donne la
possibilité d'avoir confiance dans
l'avenir si les français se sentent
responsables et s'ils ont confiance en
eux nous avons en dépit des obstacles
les moyens et les atouts pour que la
france soit une nation indépendante et
moderne pour que les français jouent le
rôle qui doit être le leur en europe et
dans le monde
autrement dit ne regardez pas la france
à partir de tout ce qui est petit
agitation intrigue manoeuvre et autres
divertissements que vous observez trop
souvent regardé la france qui est tourné
vers l'avenir
c'est un immense travail collectif qui
se fait dans ce pays
je crois que les fruits vont en
bénéficier à touches et notamment aux
jeunes et en le faisant
tous ensemble nous arriverons à
construire cette société de mesure
cette société de liberté de
responsabilité et de solidarité à
laquelle nous sommes profondément
attachés
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire dans
des circonstances qui sont des
circonstances difficiles parce que je
crois que c'est dans les circonstances
difficiles que l'on doit mesurer
l'effort à faire mais que l'on doit
également savoir le put vers lequel
l'autre suite des déclarations
syndicales de rentrée andré henry de la
fédération de l'éducation nationale a
déclaré dans une conférence de presse
nous sommes prêts à participer à des
actions unitaires mais sur des objectifs
prioritaires bien délimitées et il
ajouté le gouvernement doit prendre
conscience que l'accumulation des
rancoeurs sera rapidement plus forte que
les replis sur soi provoquée par la
crainte du chômage
de son côté jean-bernard de là
cftc dit qu'elle n'exclut aucune action
qu'il n'exclut aucune action avec les
autres syndicats mais c'est du bout des
lèvres tout de même chez la cftc puisque
en même temps jean bernard estime que le
problème n'est pas seulement de
revendiquer mais de proposer des
solutions précises aux yeux des
travailleurs qu'ils sentent que les
solutions ne sont pas ça en août il ya
toujours une sorte de dialogue dans les
nuages
on pourrait dire entre la cgt et la cfdt
qui disent vouloir se rencontrer c'est
sûr mais s'accusent mutuellement de ne
pas vouloir vraiment l'unité syndicale
georges séguy répond aujourd'hui à
edmond maire d'abord sur le ton de la
polémique met ensuite en souhaitant une
entente sincère pour l'action commune
alors à la bourse
qu'est ce qui se passe encore à la
bourse sur les grandes places
internationales
on vient d'assister cette semaine un
vent de folie à une véritable ruée sur
l'or avant l'été on constatait que tous
les records de l'or avaient été battus
on se disait qu'on ne pourrait pas aller
beaucoup plus loin parce qu'il ya un
prix de l'or qui ne signifie plus rien
sur la valeur du métal et c'est le cas
actuellement car ça recommence et cette
semaine avec de nouveaux records 48 1900
francs le lingot 460 francs le napoléon
ça c'était les prix d'hier et
aujourd'hui a eu tout de même une
accalmie le lingot a perdu 1000 francs
et le napoléon 7 francs mais les
spécialistes disent que c'est
certainement une accalmie technique
certains spéculateurs ont revendu pour
prendre leurs bénéfices tout de suite et
les mêmes spécialistes s'attendent à une
nouvelle flambée la semaine prochaine
bref ceux qui jouent sur l'or à la
bourse doivent avoir les nerfs solides
quand on parle de l'or on évoque avec un
clin d'oeil le bas de laine des français
ont les qu'on le compare où on compare
les français trop facilement à l'oncle
picsou qui arrange ses petites pièces
d'or dans les trous de son mur
je voudrais bien savoir et vous aussi où
est cet or là ce n'est sûrement pas
celui qui a fait souffler le vent de
folie de la semaine dernière essayons de
voir avec alain weiler comment on peut
expliquer les comportements des vrais
spéculateurs de l'or londres 1971 la
séance du fixing au siège de la banque
rothschild ou s'établit chaque jour
depuis 1919
le cours qui va déterminer le prix de
l'or
sur toutes les grandes places
financières 41 dollar hier au salon se
jouera le cours fixé aujourd'hui huit
ans plus tard et 8 fois plus élevés à
paris le cours fixé à midi à la bourse
suit l'évolution du cours à londres le
dépassant de 5 à 6%
à paris aussi l'or a subi une hausse
vertigineuse ces dernières mêlées
thésauriseurs ne sont pas gagnants à
tout coup regardez cette courbe du cours
du lingot une courbe en dents de scie
ceux qui ont acheté fin 1974 ont dû
attendre plus de trois ans avant de
pouvoir revendre sans perte
le syndic des agents de change peu et
hier soir sur tf1
la démonstration suivante le napoléon va
les 8000 anciens francs en 1948 8000
francs de l'époque représentait en
pouvoir d'achat ça sans prendre
aujourd'hui le même napoléon valait 81
nouveau front en 1968 200 enfants
d'aujourd'hui
il n'a pas encore retrouvé son pouvoir
d'achat de l'époque
la hausse actuelle va-t-elle se
poursuivre l'analyse des causes de cette
hausse peut faire craindre que oui la
fièvre sur l'or s'explique d'abord par
la fuite devant le dollar qui ne valait
plus aujourd'hui que 4 francs 23 à la
bourse de paris
on n'a plus confiance en la politique
économique de carter alors que les états
unis connaissent à nouveau inflation et
stagnation qui achètent les américains
eux-mêmes tout d'abord après la grande
crise économique de 1929
roosevelt leur avait interdit d'acquérir
de l'or mais depuis cinq ans les
transactions sur le lingot sont de
nouveau autorisées et les américains
sont devenus des spéculateurs effréné
traitant l'or comme il traitait le sucre
par exemple mais les plus gros acheteurs
ce sont les pays arabes producteurs de
pétrole
la seule hausse du prix du brut l'aurora
rapporté 45 milliards de dollars 190
milliards de francs cette année
des dollars qui leur brûlent les doigts
d de l'art difficile à placer dans
l'industrie en cette période de crise
des dollars dont une partie se
transforme en or désorganisant le marché
chacun se pose aujourd'hui la question
que va-t-il se passer lundi
car si l'or peut enrichir quelques
spéculateurs il peut aussi désorganiser
les économies mondiales
s'il continue à monter entraînant la
chute du dollar les pays pétroliers
augmenteront encore le prix du pétrole
ce qui accentuera la crise des économies
le laboratoire américain de l'espace
pioneer 11 a fini son exploration de
saturne
sur terre les scientifiques font le
bilan
et c'est un sixième anneaux de saturne
auraient été découverts et peut-être un
douzième satellite peut-être un douzième
satellite de saturne mais c'est pas sûr
il faudra aller y voir de plus près avec
les voyageurs ce qu'ils sont des
laboratoires plus perfectionnés mais
pionnière 11 a provoqué une déception
tout de même ses photos et ses
informations fait savoir la terre qu'il
n'y avait pas de vie possible sur titan
le plus gros satellite de saturne un
moment on a cru qu'il pouvait y avoir
une certaine forme de vie sur titan
françois de closets
oui c'est vrai c'est une petite
déception mais il faut tout même se
rendre compte que cette mission que ni
aux est tout à fait extraordinaire alors
je voudrais tout de suite vous montrer
deux photos qui nous ont été transmises
par pionnier ans
voilà vous allez voir cette première
photo et je le sais vous allez être déçu
si la photo des anneaux de saturne
et puis une deuxième photo de saturne
ces photos vous le voyez ne sont pas
très belles ces photos de saturne sont
moins bonnes que les meilleurs qu'on a
prises depuis la terre parce sur les
photos brut
seulement on a complètement oublié la
performance extraordinaire d'envoyer des
signaux d'un milliard et demi de
kilomètres et bien pour les recevoir
dans ce fouillis de bruit de fond il
faut un énorme travail d'ordinateurs et
ces documents vont être améliorée
considérablement par un traitement et ça
prend un certain temps ce pourquoi par
exemple on annonce que maintenant la
découverte de ce 6e à nous alors
revoyons toute cette mission sur une
extraordinaire animation qui bien sûr ça
ne vous étonnera pas a été réalisé avec
l'aide d'un ordinateur
cette mission deux pionniers ont songé
qu'il n'y a que 30 kg d'appareils
scientifiques à bord de cet engin qui
est une sonde planétaire de première
génération mais qui déjà nous a fourni
toutes sortes de renseignements sur
saturne saturn c'est très important
c'est une grosse planète du même type
que jupiter mais moins
monde - en furie il il ya ainsi des
tourbillons de gaz extraordinaire mais
sans doute moins énorme que ce qui se
passe sur jupiter en comparant les deux
on va mieux comprendre ce phénomène de
ces grosses planètes qui sont un peu
comme des étoiles avorté et puis donc
c'est à nous maintenant on sait qu'il y
en a 6 mai vous le voyez il a fallu des
jours de dépouillement pour découvrir
cela et puis surtout on attend des
titans donc parce que comme depuis la
terre on avait vu autour de ce satellite
mais qui à la masse à peu près de mars
n'est ce pas on avait vu de l'atmosphère
de méthane
on se disait que c'était peut-être un
bon berceau sur la vie mais une
condition qu'il fallait qu'il ait assez
faux sur titan parce que le berceau de
la vie doit être un peu chaud alors
quand on a braqué les engins sur titan
eh bien on à capter des signaux et on
n'a pas retrouvé l'information alors un
moment
voyez ici la simulation de titans qui
apparaît on s'est dit c'est un satellite
soviétique qui avec ses émissions nous a
brouillé pas du tout le coupable c'est
le soleil ce bain de soleil c'est un
énorme émetteurs d'ondés radio est bien
là le soleil était en colère ils
émettaient encore plus donc à juillet
tesla et quand on a pu analyser ces
idiots eh bien on a vu qu'il fait très
froid trop froid sans doute sur titan
alors ce pour qu'il y ait une évolution
biologique n'a jamais cru qu'il y avait
des petits kahnien alors ça veut dire
qu'il n'ya pas ultra non pas d'être
vivant dans l'univers n'avait jamais
pensé même pas d'évolution biologique
on aurait aimé voir le début de cette
évolution pour comprendre l'origine de
la vie sur terre
eh bien nous savons maintenant que pour
avoir une preuve directe que nous ne
sommes pas seuls dans l'univers
il faudra écouter et attendre pour
peut-être capter des signaux envoyés par
des extraterrestres oui c'est ça en tout
cas c'est vrai qu'il ya un souhait
évident avec cette exploration un
souhait que nous ressentons c'est que
nous devrions trouver des compagnons
dans l'univers et que peut-être nous
nous sentons assez désespérément seul
sur notre planète
jean claude narcy les autres nouvelles
de ce journal mais d'abord il ya de
nouvelles tensions entre la chine et le
vietnam les chinois sont en train de
masser douzy vision aussi corps d'armée
à proximité de la frontière vietnamienne
il construit également les
fortifications dans la même région
c'est la radio ou vietnamienne qu'il a
annoncé aujourd'hui au japon le
premier ministre a décidé de dissoudre
la diète c'est à dire la chambre des
représentants en effet l'opposition
avait l'intention de déposer une motion
de censure
il y aura deux prochaines élections au
japon probablement le 7 octobre prochain
un raid rhodésien dans la province de
gaza au mozambique a fait plus de 300
tués chez les gris et rose du front
patriotique c'est ce qu'annonce un
communiqué aura les yeux c'est lundi je
vous rappelle que s'ouvre à londres la
conférence constitutionnelle sur la
rhodésie avec la participation donc de
plusieurs dirigeants du front
patriotique ainsi qu'une délégation
rhodésienne dirigé par le premier
ministre rhodésien demain dans notre
édition de 13 heures georges marchais à
la fête annuelle de l'humanité répondra
aux questions des journalistes du
service politique de tf1
à cette occasion le leader communiste
pourrait bien donner certaines
précisions sur la rencontre du 20
septembre prochain entre communistes et
socialistes
la fête de l'humanité je le rappelle se
tient demain et dimanche au parc
paysager de la courneuve près de paris
les plaintes déposées contre robert
hersant pour infraction à la législation
sur l'organisation de la presse ont été
déclarés aujourd'hui recevable par le
premier juge d'instruction du tribunal
de paris
monsieur k billet c'est son nom estime
que la concentration d'entreprises de
presse dans les mains d'un même pouvoir
de fait est de nature à porter atteinte
au libre exercice de la profession de
journaliste
80000 litre de supercarburant se sont
déversés ce matin dans la zone
industrielle de longue vie dans la
banlieue de dijon après le déraillement
d'un wagon-citerne trois wagons d'un
convoi sortant des dépôts l'essence ont
déraillé pour une cause encore
indéterminée
l'un d'entre eux a donc dû verser la
totalité du contenu en contrebas de la
voie ferrée les services de protection
civile sont intervenus très rapidement
et ont neutralisé le carburant avec de
la mousse physique
une garde est assurée pendant 24 heures
autour du lieu de l'accident pour éviter
évidemment tout risque d'incendié
yves mourousi monsieur moto s'est
déclaré aujourd'hui favorables à un
nouveau permis pour les motocyclistes
compte tenu du nombre croissant des
accidentés mais il se déclare contre la
vignette qui risque d'entraîner un
supplément de dépense pour les jeunes
qui consacre déjà une bonne partie de
leur budget à la pratique motocyclistes
ce soir d'ailleurs dix mille motards
seront sur la place de la bastille pour
protester contre cette vignette bien
nous venons de je crois de recevoir des
images rejet des images c'est de l'avion
où les quatre kurdes vous le savez
auteurs du détournement du dc 8 des
l'italien ont accepté de libérer les
40 des 175 passagers je pense et ce sont
ces images là que nous allons recevoir
que nous prouve à saâles et voilà alors
je crois que on doit apercevoir les
passagers qui descendent par petits
groupes de cinq ou six personnes comme
le disait tout à l'heure notre envoyé
spécial permanent en italie peut bomber
de l'homme brevets lycée passage et donc
doivent quitter l'appareil qui était
même immobilisé depuis le début de
l'après-midi sur cet aéroport de rome et
ils sont ses passagers vous les voyez
descendre directement dirigé vers les
salles de transit de l'aéroport de rome
alors évidemment cette image a été prise
de très très loin avec un téléobjectif
on ne devine premier ce pourquoi ils
tremblent et c'est pourquoi elles ne
sont pas très nettes mais on voit que la
libérale et wal mart dealers âgés est
intervenue et selon les dernières
dépêches le ravitaillement en kérosène
du dc 8 aurait commencé et il y aurait
un plan de vol fournis par la compagnie
alitalia l'avion détourné pour pourrait
donc rejoindre ainsi la havane sans
escale dit-on ans 10h45 voleurs voici
donc les images je ne sais pas si elles
sont directs que si elles sont en
différé c'est peut-être d ivato petit
peu en différé
il ya quelques instants voilà revenons
au reste de l'activité épidémie de
choléra au zaïre
le bilan provisoire est de 3500 morts et
trente six mille personnes atteints
depuis le début de l'année la maladie a
même atteint kinshasa la capitale à la
fin du mois dernier les vaccins ont été
envoyés par plusieurs pays du monde pour
enrayer cette épidémie
jean marie giraud le sénateur maire udf
de caen veut relancer le débat sur la
toxicomanie la demande et même une
audience au président de la république
monsieur giraud déposera une proposition
de loi tendant à la création d'un
institut de recherche et d'enseignement
sur la toxicomanie
le maire de caen vous le savez
sensibilisés à ce problème de la drogue
son propre fils avait été inculpé dans
une affaire concernant la drogue en 1977
c'est d'ailleurs pour la drogue qu'un
jeune homme de 17 ans serait mort à
rouen le jeune frédéric a été tué par
deux de ses amis qui ont expliqué le
mobile de leurs crimes en affirmant que
frédéric avait dérobé une dizaine de
grammes de haschisch
il y a quelques semaines leur avait
dérobé marie marquez a eu aujourd'hui à
paris les accès que sans doute elle
désirait puisque c'est elle même qui
voyant la mort venue en avait réglé
l'ordonance la plus vieille église de
paris juchés sur la butte montmartre
l'église saint pierre
des personnalités voyez grace de monaco
mais aussi tout un petit peuple amical
ému dimanche couronne mais également
d'un bhl bouquets de fleurs des champs
au cours de la fils le chanoine gallic
vous voyez ici qui fut lui-même
d'ailleurs un grand acteur avant de
rejoindre les hordes il fut l'homme à
l'hispano suis à adi de marie marquée
elle fut tout amour amour de la vie des
hommes et de son âne open des états unis
les demi-finales des championnats vont
donc des états unis opposés quatre
américains gary la tis à tannerre et
connors le favori à mcenroe john mcenroe
qui vont nous voir ici éliminé son
compatriote lee basse après un match où
les précisions des juges n'ont pas
toujours plus aux joueurs
et puis américaine crise et verts s'est
qualifié pour la finale du simple dames
de l'open des états unis 7
cet après midi elle a éliminé sa
compatriote billie jean king et dimanche
je vous le rappelle à 22 heures sur tf1
en direct et bien nous aurons la finale
de l'open hommes le temps est bien
depuis hier les températures ont subi
une hausse dans le nord-est et le
centre-est mais ailleurs elles sont
restées sur le elles sont restées les
mêmes ces températures sauf sur la
région parisienne où on notait une
baisse sensible et demain le temps sera
bien ensoleillé sur les régions
méditerranéennes et sur le sud des alpes
et sur le reste de la france après des
brumes matinales de belles éclaircies se
développeront
toutefois quelques pluies ou ondées
orageuses résiduelles comme on dit
pourrait être observé des pyrénées au
massif central au cours de la journée le
ciel se couvrira de la bretagne et de la
vendée ou contentin les vents se
renforceront sur la bretagne les
températures seront en hausse
dans le sud ouest alors dimanche
prochain aura lieu à monza en italie
l'un des trois derniers grands prix de
formule 1 de la saison avant le grand
prix du canada le 30 septembre et celui
de la côte est des états unis
huit jours plus tard il reste encore une
toute petite chance je dis bien une
toute petite à jacques laffite sur
ligier de rattraper le sud-africain
sectaires sur ferrari pour le
championnat du monde des conducteurs
mais pour nous français
l'intérêt de la course de monza c'est
aussi ailleurs c'est dans les renault
équipée de pneus michelin et renault qui
souhaite absolument confirmer sa seule
victoire de la saison au grand prix de
france de dijon or que se passe-t-il
vous savez qu'un grand prix durant fait
trois jours avant la course il ya deux
séances d'essais le vendredi et le
samedi
les temps réalisés à ces essais
détermine les place dans la grille de
départ
et qu'y trouve-t-on en tête aujourd'hui
aux essais et bien je dirais presque
comme d'habitude
rené arnoux sur sa renault turbo oui
rené arnoux le plus vite sur ce circuit
comme en autriche et comme aux pays-bas
et j'espère qu'on ne pourra pas dire
cette fois ci jamais deux sans trois en
autriche rené arnoux était tombé en
panne d'essence dans la course aux pays
bas rené arnoux avait été éliminé dès le
départ sur un choc terrible avec la
williams de regazzoni
alors on espère que cette fois s'il pour
aller jusqu'au bout dans la
démonstration de son talent mais qui
connaissait rené arnoux ya six mois
ce pilote de formule 1 aujourd'hui parmi
les meilleurs est un grand timide et la
renault formule 1 n'en était qu'à la
mise au point bernard giroud va nous
faire découvrir dans l'intimité ce
garçon modeste qui sait si bien
dissimuler son étoffe de grands
champions
là bas voici arnould deschamps et
arnould des pistes cet homme tranquille
de la campagne nivernaise est celui qui
pilote la voiture jaune c'était au grand
prix de france à dijon le fameux devait
la veille villeneuve entre la renault et
la ferrari les roues qui se touchent à
220 km heure une course à sensation avec
des petits bonhommes qui ne paye pas de
mine
cela n'empêche pas arnould d'aimer la
nature et les animaux
elle appelle casting est le net parce
que j'espère que j'ai un couple pour
voir des petits et vous comptez agrandir
la ménagerie non pas pour le moment
parce que là ménagé c'est beaucoup dire
puisque les gars avec les métiers qui
pratique c'est impossible
courir pour assouvir sa passion
telle est la devise de cet anti star du
sport automobile la formule c'est une
question de moyens
alors est ce que l'argent c'est
important pour vous c'est sur l'argent
est important mais je crois que
actuellement je cours pas par pure
passion parce que parce que j aime
conduire une monoplace et excès c'est
grisant c'est passionnant et est évident
que
avec la formule 1 je gagne de l'argent
mais je ne cours pas pour gagner de
l'argent mon au départ c'est vraiment
parce que je suis passionné que j'aime
ça champion d'europe de formule 2 rdr
nous devient le lutin de la formule 1 je
pense que beaucoup de gens me l'ont dit
que rené arnoux change complètement
lorsqu'il est au volant de sa voiture
bien sûr je suis assez réservée timide
oui mais ça m'a un peu passé et
heureusement mais voilà ma voiture
une place est une place à ce moment-là
je cours pour gagner donc c'est
peut-être un autre côté de general levy
arnaud quelles sont les qualités de rené
de qualité drones et je pense qu'avant
tout il a beaucoup beaucoup de volonté a
pas avoir obtenu deux pole positions
le prochain objectif pour rené arnoux et
de remporter un grand prix de la volonté
ils ont faux dans ce type de compétition
alors les meilleurs temps aux essais de
monza donne pour l'instant premier donc
rené arnoux deuxième alan jones
l'australien kalinic qui a gagné les
trois derniers grands prix sur williams
3e gilles villeneuve le canadien sur
ferrari 4e regazzoni le suisse sur
l'autre williams 5e
jodie scheckter sur ferrari 6e jean
pierre jabouille sur l'autre renault
laffitte sur ligier est 10e et on
retrouve en tête aux essais exactement
les mêmes aux deux précédents grands
prix dimanche dans sport première
vous pourrez suivre un long reportage
sur ce grand prix de monza
enfin une confirmation attendue en
particulier par les pilotes jabouille et
arnould piloteront les formule 1 renault
dans tous les grands prix l'année
prochaine voilà bonne soirée à tous au
nom de toute l'équipe de tf1 qualité
dernier journal vers 23h10 avec bernard
chevalier merci de votre attention